all right so Greg uh your segment today
what do you have for us uh yeah so I am
talking about uh partial range of motion
training uh specifically for strength so
um I I partnered with Milo Wolff who uh
recently pre-printed a meta-analysis
examining uh the research looking at the
impact of range of motion on strength
development muscle growth uh Etc and we
have a very in-depth article that is
going to drop on November 1st I believe
this episode is going to be published in
full on the 31st
um so if if you're listening to the full
episode and not uh one of the clips that
gets posted on YouTube beforehand that
article will be up tomorrow
um but I think most of the current
interest around this topic is related to
the impact of longer versus shorter
ranges of motion and training at longer
versus shorter muscle lengths on
hypertrophy but there is some some
pretty interesting research looking at
the effect of partial range of motion
training per se but more importantly
combining partial and full range of
motion training for improving full range
of motion strength gains so that is what
this segment is going to be talking
about
um so Eric have you have you ever experi
experimented much with partial range of
motion training things like rack pulls
board press Etc yeah for sure what's
what's your uh what's your your current
Vibe around those training practices and
and what's what's your experience
um well back in the day a great way to
make my bench press seem higher was to
simply not go as low so that was my
first Venture into uh into limited range
of motion training uh no I my
perspective has been poisoned because
I've read all of the mass articles as a
reviewer of mass so I I'm kind of up to
speed with what the research shows but I
know like you know for me I when I was
you know back in the day before looking
into all the literature I would use
partial range of motion stuff for a
variety of different reasons I mean
sometimes if I was sometimes it's very
intuitive right so like I used to do
like you know uh various uh bench press
variations and you could tell when you'd
get that stretch at the bottom of the
rep you could really feel your pecs
stretching out I mean I would crank half
repetitions in that lengthen position
like crazy and just you know you feel
the burn and the pump and all that stuff
so even before looking looking at the
research it was very clear to me you
know there is something different here
to some extent about altering range of
motion so I think partials partials on
bench on both sides of the spectrum are
really the biggest thing that I would
that I would do nice cool yeah I I'm in
a I'm in a similar boat uh used to do a
lot of pin press used to do a lot of
board press
um also really really enjoy block polls
uh used to do a ton of rack pulls until
like
and until I I basically just got strong
enough that it would bend bars like rack
pulls are very very rough on bars that
that's not in I'm very strong statement
that is a if you do rack pulls with a
fair bit of weight that's very rough on
bars statement
um but yeah like I I like partials I
think they're fun
um
but I think that they have fallen out of
favor in a lot of circles these days
um I think that people became you know
generally acquainted with the principle
of specificity the idea that hey if I
want to get strong through a full range
of motion I should train through a full
range of motion and especially like
overload type partials so things like uh
board press or pin press or block poles
or half squats uh they've been I think
in the general consciousness of the
lifting Community kind of consigned to
to the bin of ego lifting
um you know where where maybe if you're
doing equipped to lifting where lockout
strength might be a really big concern
ah maybe they have a role but if
especially if you're trying to do raw
lifting
um I I just don't see as much partial
range of motion training as I used to
like it really seems to have fallen out
of favor but but partial range of motion
training uh through again through short
muscle links so like overload partials
do have a a long and illustrious history
in in the strength community so two of
the two of the great pioneers at least
of like the American strength training
tradition uh built some pretty legendary
lifts uh on the backs of a lot of
partials so uh one was Bob peoples who I
believe is the first person to ever
deadlift over 700 pounds
um his best deadlift was 728 at 181
which uh which he pulled in 1946 I
believe which if he did it today would
still be the 12th best deadlift all time
in the 181 class uh for for like drug
tested federations and which I mean like
I don't think steroids had reached the
Backwoods of Tennessee which is where
Bob peoples was from in 1946 but even if
you're like ah like he he somehow had
the gear hook up a year after World War
II
um like that poll would still be top 50
at 181 even counting untested Fed so
like uh just just Leaps and Bounds ahead
of the competition back in the 40s
um he did a lot of you know what we
would know today as rackpoles to build
his deadlift a lot of deadlifts from
just below knee height just above uh
knee height in order to build his
lockout strength and then uh another
very famous example is Paul Anderson
um who built his his legendary and I
used that that term with all of all of
the assumed connotations legendary both
in terms of it was doubtlessly a very
impressive squat but legendary also in
the term of it may have been a Legend
and his squat wasn't as good as people
have claimed
um but yeah like an incredible squatter
um who it is claimed that he potentially
squatted 1200 pounds which uh I don't
know how much I buy that but also when
you see pictures of the guy
he looks like the type of guy who might
have been able to squat 1200 pounds hard
to say but um he was famous for like one
of his squat training methods is he
would dig a hole and basically just have
like a squat bar on the ground and get
down into the hole and just do partial
reps and then once he could do I think
like eight to ten reps at a at a certain
height he would just put some dirt in
the hole so now the hole is not quite as
deep and the range of motion is a little
bit longer and you know do partial
squats that way as well
um so if you've ever heard of people
referring to bottom up pin squats as
Anderson squats that's why
um but just very cool very Innovative uh
you know you don't have a squat rack you
can just dig a hole very cool stuff also
just as an aside Paul Anderson did all
sorts of just like very fun sounding
training back in the day uh one story
and this is a little bit far afield but
it's it's a nice story that I think
people people should know so he was he
was most famous I think for just really
really incredible squat strength and
really really incredible overhead press
strength and one of the things he used
to do is he he had a farm he had a lot
of land and he just enjoyed golf like
like his as an amateur golfer I like I
don't think he was particularly good but
I I imagine it was it was a situation
where he could he could slap a drive a
mile
um and he would set up a squat rack on
either end of his big field and load
like 800 pounds on one of the bars and
like 400 pounds on the other bar and
just go out there with his driver a golf
ball and like a gallon of milk and start
on on the squat rack with 800 pounds do
a couple reps of squats smack the ball
across the field sipping on his milk as
he went this was in Tennessee
um no no uh Bob peoples was from
Tennessee Paul Anderson was from some
somewhere in the South I think Georgia
but don't don't quote me on that okay
because when you said milk my first stop
was the old Anchorman milk was a bad
choice I just I just think of being like
98 Degrees squatting 800 gallon of milk
I mean I am good I guess he was just
built different yeah uh anyway smack the
ball to the other end of the field do
like two or three reps of shoulder press
with the 400 pound bar and then just
smack the ball back uh so you know
getting some steps in getting some low
intensity cardio and and just making a
day of of doing squats and overhead
press uh very very cool anyway so yeah
there's a there's a proud history of
partials in the strength training uh
tradition and one thing I'll note is the
um the story of Paul Anderson allegedly
squatting 1200 pounds is
far more interesting than I realized I
found a really cool article on breaking
muscle that will be linked in the show
notes
um essentially just breaking down how
plausible it was for it to have
potentially happened like essentially
the apparatus used for his alleged 1200
pound squat could it have actually held
1200 pounds
um like like what were the incentives
around this because essentially it was
it was a show
um where he was performing in a Casino
in Reno Nevada and instead of just like
a squat bar it was too big uh metal and
glass boxes that were allegedly loaded
with
um like 15 000 silver dollars so 7500 in
one box 7500 in the other box and that
in combination with the weight of the
apparatus itself was allegedly depending
who you ask either eleven hundred and
sixty pounds or 1200 pounds and he would
apparently uh go and squat it for a
crowd with kind of the the old the old
time circus strongman Gambit of if
anyone else in the audience can do this
uh you can have the the 1500 bucks which
this was I think in the 50s so that was
a ton of money back then and so you know
the article gets into well you know
it probably wasn't actually 1200 pounds
but there were other strong people back
then
um and so there there was incentive for
it to be very very heavy because if it
wasn't and someone else claimed that
money you know the casino's out of
fifteen fifteen thousand dollars
um and also like the fact that it was
silver dollars is important because this
intersected with debates in the U.S at
the time about should we move to the
silver standard versus the gold standard
or like paper money all of that like
Williams Janine Bryan stuff
um and and the the folks who ran this
casino in Nevada were very into the idea
of a silver standard which you just
don't see that many overlaps between
power lifting and monetary policy so a
very cool story anyway intro out of the
way let's uh let's actually get into the
research on the topic
so
um in general I think we all kind of
know and acknowledge this for the most
part if you had to pick one training
modality like if you had to pick one
type of range of motion to train through
and you wanted to build strength through
a full range of motion you should do
full range of motion training that is
not particularly controversial that's uh
strongly empirically supported
um uh in Milo's meta-analysis that was
one of the things they looked at and
like yeah for tests of full range of
motion strength full range of motion
training works better than partial range
of motion training like that's uh that's
not uh controversial at all however most
people who would be doing some partial
range of motion training are also still
going to be doing full range of motion
training as well like if you're a power
lifter and you want to do some block
pulls you'll probably still be doing
deadlifts from the floor if you want to
do some board press you'll probably
still be doing plenty of bench press to
your chest so I think the more
interesting and relevant question is
what does the research have to say about
combining different ranges of motion
instead of just doing full range of
motion training versus just doing
partial range motion training because
you know in in science we like to be
able to create clear dichotomies isolate
variables and just say Okay full range
versus partial range what are the
differences but at least for uh for
ecological validity to better reflect
how people train in the real world I I
think the the research looking at a
combination of different ranges of
motion is just a lot more informative
about
um what you could expect using the
methods that people would actually use
in real training so uh yeah let's let's
dive in there are four relevant studies
that I'm going to discuss here briefly
the first one was by Basler and
colleagues from 2014. uh all of the
studies I I mentioned will be in the
show notes and so in this study
one group so there were two groups of
subjects one group
um
just trained squats through a full range
of motion doing six sets twice per week
and the other group uh also trained
squats twice per week doing three sets
through a full range of motion and three
sets of partial squats so through about
80 degrees of knee flexion or or roughly
half squats so the total number of sets
were equated but one group just did all
full squats the other group did 50 50
full squats and half squats it was a
seven week training intervention and uh
long story short there weren't
statistically significant differences
between groups but the nominal
differences did Lean in favor of the
group doing a combination of full and
partial range of motion training so
their one rep max full squat increased
by about 8.2 percent on average versus
5.1 percent in the group only doing full
squats and also the the group doing a
combination of full and partial squats
experience nominally larger gains in
partial squat when rep max as well
though that is not particularly
surprising moving on the second study
was by Gillingham and debaliso and I'll
note the Gillingham in this study is
Brad Gillingham which if you're into
power lifting at all uh I assume you
know who Brad Gillingham is and if you
don't shame on you he is an absolute
Legend he won six World Championships in
power lifting and uh I I believe he has
still to this day pulled more than 800
pounds in competition more discreet
times than any other human just a
legendary deadlifter uh and his his best
deadlift was uh 400 kilos in in the
super heavyweight class so
it's it's very cool to see him uh
getting into the lab getting his hands
dirty and I'll note if if uh you're
listening to this and and you ever
encounter the perspective of someone
online being like ah man uh exercise
science researchers they don't know
anything about real strength training
that at least one of them does uh Brad
Gillingham absolute Legend in
powerlifting so in this group it was or
in this study it was a six-week training
study
um in a group of Collegiate wrestlers uh
undergoing their pre-season training
program and uh one group just did full
range of motion deadlifts
um the other group subbed out one of
those sets of full range of motion
deadlifts for uh three singles through a
partial range of motion from just above
uh the kneecap so the the total number
of sets weren't equated between groups
but the the group doing full only full
range of motion training it was like it
it was sets that looked like pretty
challenging sets of five and the the
singles for the the block polls that
they did or rack pulls weren't with like
super super super max loads not like 150
percent of one RM as someone who's done
a lot of deadlift training the the total
stress that the two groups under went I
think was more or less equivalent just
just that is my my personal belief
um but yeah so they they trained for six
weeks uh the group only doing full range
of motion training uh actually
experienced a small non-significant
decrease in strength uh of about uh 5.3
kilos on their full full range of motion
deadlift whereas the group doing a
combination of full and partial range of
motion training uh experienced a small
increase in deadlift strength of about
4.5 kilos so again much like the Basler
study that didn't amount to a
statistically significant difference
between groups but the nominal
difference did did Lean in favor of
doing a combination of full and partial
range of motion training instead of just
full range of motion and then once again
very unsurprisingly uh the group doing
some partial range of motion training
also experienced a significantly larger
gains in uh rackpole strength so they
they tested one one rep max for rack
pulls as well
uh moving on third study was by Pedrosa
and colleagues this one I believe was
published in 2021 and it's not exactly
uh the same as the prior study so the
prior two studies compared full range of
motion training versus a combination of
full and partial range motion training
this one compared full range of motion
training to a combination of two
different partial ranges of motion so
one group did knee extensions through a
full range of motion the other group did
half of their sets through a partial
range of motion through the bottom half
of the lift and half of their sets
through a partial range of motion
through the top half of the lift so a
combination of two different partial
ranges of motion
um and uh yeah overall this one was very
similar they they trained for 12 weeks
uh there were overall uh five groups in
this study so if you're watching on
YouTube when we uh throw up the figure
from the study you will see uh five bars
but the the two that are relevant for
this discussion here will have a red box
around them
um but yeah uh so they they tested uh
strength gains in this study through uh
the bottom half of the range of motion
so so partial range of motion strength
through the bottom half partial range of
motion strength through the top half and
also uh full range of motion strength
gains through the full range of motion
uh and in all cases the combination of
those two partial ranges of motion
produce larger strength gains than just
training through a full range of motion
again even when equating uh total sets
and the difference was statistically
significant for strength gains through
the bottom half of the range of motion
but for full range of motion strength
gains as we saw in the Basler study and
the Gillingham study nominal differences
in favor of the partials but it wasn't a
statistically significant difference
then finally the last of these four
studies 2020 paper by Whaley and
colleagues
um and and this one was slightly
different again instead of so the other
the other three studies essentially
you'd have one group doing full range of
motion training and the other groups
basically doing half of their training
through a full range of motion or
through the bottom half of the range of
motion and half of their training
through a partial range of motion and
short muscle lengths and you know like
50 50 per session per week whatever in
the Whaley study they used Progressive
range of motion training much like uh
Paul Anderson filling in that hole for
his Progressive range of motion squats
this was a seven week training study
there was one group squatting through a
full range of motion every session and
another group doing Progressive range of
motion training so they were doing pin
squats basically starting from like a
quarter squat height with the pins
getting lower and lower and lower each
workout such that by week seven it was
basically doing pin squats through
effectively a full range of motion
um and once again just like the other
three studies they tested full range of
motion squat one rep max and there
wasn't a statistically significant
difference between groups but the
nominal differences once again leaned in
favor of the group doing a combination
of full and partial range of motion
training in this case it was Progressive
range of motion training so that group
experienced a 14 and a half kilo
increase in squat one rep max on average
versus 11 kilos for the group only doing
full range motion training and also in
this study they looked at gains in
vertical jump height which were also
nominally larger in the group doing
Progressive range of motion training so
when you look at these four studies in
aggregate
um you know it's it's a bit of a
Rorschach test I would say
um if you wanted to interpret them very
very conservatively you could say hey
scientists have had four bites at the
Apple this time and have thus far failed
to fail to demonstrate statistically
significant differences between these
two training Styles or you could
interpret it a little more liberally and
say well look you know the the concept
of statistical significance is kind of
arbitrary in the first place
um you know is is p of 0.07 really that
different from P of 0.03 uh and
ultimately we have four relatively
similar studies finding very similar
results
um so you know maybe there's something
to it and ultimately I'm
still skeptical but bullish I would say
like I would want to see another couple
of studies uh like I I think if we got
two more studies that also showed kind
of nominal differences in favor of the
combination even if they weren't
statistically significant or just one
more study where there was like a pretty
big statistically significant very
notable difference between the two
approaches I'd be like yeah yeah like at
this point we can probably cash this in
put put a pretty pretty substantial
number of eggs in that basket
um but yeah it's it's to me right now
kind of right on that knife's edge of of
how seriously we should take this
um but it I mean the the balance of
evidence to this point does broadly
suggest that a combination of full and
partial range of motion training
probably on average produces slightly
larger strength gains than exclusively
training through a full range of motion
then the next the next obvious question
is well why would that be and
to be honest I'm not sure
um it could simply be a matter of
variety so there was a 2014 paper by
Fonseca and colleagues to kind of use as
an object lesson here where there were
two groups in that study that only did
squats and two groups in that study that
did squats and also a variety of other
lower body exercises but
you know uh like for example the two
groups just doing squats I think wound
up doing like eight sets of squats per
workout and the group's doing a variety
of exercises would do two sets of squats
two sets I think of deadlifts two sets
of lunges or something like that maybe
two sets of uh uh essentially like [ __ ]
squat something like that I I forget all
of the details but that that was the
basic setup and uh the groups doing a
variety of different exercises in that
study uh gained more squat strength than
the groups just doing squats uh which
suggests that you know like you you
certainly need specificity to gain
strength but there there might just be
some inherent benefit to having some
variety and not being hyper specific all
the time so you know in this case that
could be all we're seeing you know maybe
maybe partial range of motion training
isn't like super beneficial per se but
just like subbing out a third or a half
of your full range of motion training
like if you're doing 20 sets of
full range of motion squats you know
maybe like competition style maybe
subbing out 10 of those sets for half
squats or pin squats or pause squats or
box squats or band squats or just like
basically anything else like it could we
could just be seen an effect that is
attributable to variety rather than
partial range of motion training per se
um
it's it I think this is uh somewhat
dubious but I I think I would get called
out for it if I didn't at least mention
it one uh one kind of like historical
reason that that people have cited in
the past for why like overload style
partial short muscle length partials
that that you can just load heavier than
full range of motion training one reason
people have proposed that those might be
beneficial is that they could have uh
like outsized effects on connective
tissue strength or bone strength which
you know Downstream of that that might
result in larger strength gains to my
knowledge there's not much if any direct
evidence for this
um and the research we do have looking
at uh like changes in in tendon strength
with training tends to suggest that load
actually isn't all that important like
resistance training is good but as long
as it's like a reasonably challenging
load it seems to have like pretty
comparable effects on gains and tendon
strength so I'm pretty skeptical about
that but you know that is a potential
mechanism that hasn't been directly
investigated so can't fully rule it out
and then another possibility is that it
could be mostly psychological where uh
especially for one rep max testing and
especially for people who aren't that
experienced with one rep max testing
there there's kind of the the oh [ __ ]
factor you know like if if you're
attempting a new one rep max bench
attempting a new one rep max squat uh as
soon as you unrack that weight and feel
it in your hands or on your shoulders
maybe you're capable of it but
Jesus Christ it's just [ __ ] scary you
know uh if you've never touched anything
that heavy before so you know it could
be that uh overload partials just help
on that front just get you used to
feeling more weight so that maybe they
don't actually make you that much
stronger but they kind of help you
psychologically be able to lift the
weights you are actually capable of
lifting without just kind of shutting
down and locking up when you feel those
really heavy one rep max attempts it'd
be really cool if someone were to do a
study uh where they did like for example
if they were looking at squats and had
the you know had one of the groups just
doing walkouts to try to kind of be like
hey just so you know here's what this
really heavy stuff feels like yeah like
there would be a way experimentally to
get at that but I mean I assume no one's
done that I I don't believe they have
yeah
um but I I will note I don't think that
this potential explanation explains all
of these findings because the the a
Pedrosa study was looking at knee
extensions and I don't think anyone gets
like that oh [ __ ] feeling you get for a
one rep max squat when you feel a really
heavy load against your ankle for knee
extensions you know like I just I don't
think that's a thing you're not lifting
the way I'm lifting fair enough
um
but yeah so you know this is I I think a
an interesting and developing uh area of
research that that like I said I'm not
willing to put uh the the full like
unabashed stamp of approval on it I'm
not willing to put all of my eggs in the
basket of saying it is definitely
beneficial to do a combination of full
and partial range of motion training
versus just full range of motion
training like we're we're definitely not
to that point yet uh but I I do find
this this interesting and pretty
promising
um one other thing to note about these
studies is I'm mostly focused on the
gains in full range of motion one rep
max strength uh like those outcomes
because I mean quite simply I know that
that's what most of the people in our
audience care about
um but these studies did report a
variety of other benefits that also
leaned in favor of doing a combination
of full and partial range of motion
training so like I mentioned with the
pedrosis study they tested strength not
just through a full range of motion but
through the bottom of the range of
motion and the top of the range of
motion and the
variety partial range of motion group
like doing half through the bottom half
through the top that seemed to
outperform full range of motion training
through all three of those ranges of
motion in the Basler study
um there there were some measurements
looking at rate of force development
during isometric squats that stuff
leaned in favor of a combination of full
and partial range of motion training in
the Gillingham study again
non-significant difference for gains in
full range of motion deadlift strength
but a significant difference in favor of
a combination of full and partial in
terms of gain in in terms of gains in
partial range of motion deadlift
strength and then for the Whaley study
they looked at Jump height as well again
nominal difference leaning in favor of
progressive range of motion training in
in that group or in that study so you
know it seems like there's
um
it seems like there there might be just
like other small upsides of of doing a
bit of partial range of motion training
as well beyond potential beneficial
effects on full range of motion when rep
max strength gains
um so yeah like it's it's it's
interesting but uh I'm not like 100 sold
on it yet that's that's about where I'm
at so in terms of the verdict here and
and my recommendations after uh you know
going through this body of research and
ruminating and ruminating on it a little
bit
um I think that there's definitely a
situation where it does make a lot of
sense to do some partial range of motion
training uh for the purpose of strength
development and that is you know if
you're if your weakness is through the
top part of a range of motion for a
particular lift like if you miss
deadlifts at lockout if you miss bench
press at lockout probably not going to
miss squats at lockout like it's it's
mostly it's mostly uh bench press and
deadlift but you know in in that case uh
board press pin press block pulls rack
pulls might make a ton of sense to add
in independent of just like the general
the generalized effects of combining
ranges of motion in your case like it
seems like the partial range of motion
training can help correct a specific
issue you have and help you develop
strength through a range of motion where
you're currently weak so for for if
you're in that boat seems like some
partial range of motion training makes
all the sense in the world if you're not
in that boat
um I'm not I'm not ready to confidently
say that subbing out some of your full
range of motion training for partials
will definitely improve strength gains
uh but but I am bullish overall
um and also like my my personal
experience with this is overall positive
um like I I don't know that I've gotten
that much out of partials for bench
press but I have gotten a lot out of
partials for deadlift in particular
um my deadlift was uh stalled in the
like low 600s for a long time and doing
Progressive range of motion deadlift
training just like starting at like 800
pounds for very very partial range of
motion deadlifts like from well above uh
knee height and you know just just going
down
um like like going down in in rack
height after I could get five or ten
reps so you know two inch range of
motion to start with once I get get 10
reps there uh drop it down a couple
inches once I could get 10 reps there
drop it down a couple inches
um and once I could pull 800 for like
like four or five reps from just below
knee height I could put the bar on the
floor and deadlift over seven like it
seemed to put about 80 pounds on my
deadlift uh doing that
um and I'll note it only seemed to work
once I've tried that again I didn't see
the same effect but at least through one
one run of partial range of motion or
like Progressive range of motion
deadlift training I got a ton of mileage
out of it so
um you know my my personal experience
with with partials at least like
partially backs up the research here
um
and just as a couple final notes uh uh
doing partial range of motion training
at Short muscle length so kind of
overload partials is probably worse for
hypertrophy than full range of motion
training so you know if you're
um if you're attempting to move up a
weight class by adding more muscle to
your frame or you know just trying to to
build more muscle fill out your frame so
you can lift more
um You probably don't want to go
overboard with with the overload
partials
um and if you do SUB out like a pretty
significant percentage of your full
range of motion training four partials
may not be a bad idea to do some
targeted accessories to kind of fill
that Gap so you know if you uh were
previously doing 20 sets of bench press
per week and you move to doing 10 sets
of full range of motion bench press in
like 10 sets of
um you know rack presses or board
presses or something like that may not
be a terrible idea to add in some
additional accessory exercises for your
pecs and triceps to kind of make up for
that difference
there's no research on that but I think
just kind of a priori that's that's
probably not a bad idea to make sure
you're not compromising hypertrophy
results and then uh finally just just as
a parting note
um I think that there is this this uh
since at least in some communities that
doing any sort of overload partial is
just purely ego lifting
um that there's no possible beneficial
effect you could get from it
um so if you know if you want to give
partials a shot maybe you do some half
squats maybe you do some block pulls
whatever if someone tries to call you
out for ego lifting uh yeah [ __ ] them
you know that's that's kind of my
perspective and uh send them to to this
episode of The Stronger by science
podcast to and tell them to use a
discount code too yeah absolutely yeah
um but yeah like they're it's to to be
extremely clear like there is some
promising research in this area it is
absolutely and very much not uh purely
ego lifting